everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're going
to deploy a test version of our react
project using now which is made by Zeit
and that's the same company that makes
next J S which is what we're using for
our react site as well
I'm gonna go through the whole process
we're gonna start out by creating a
sub-domain
with one of our urls pointing the sub
domain to the proper place we're going
to do it with a cname so there's a few
different ways that you can do this and
I'll get you all the link to the
documentation that lays out I think
there's three different ways we can do
this we're going to use this the cname
way which is is good if you don't want
to use their name servers the site name
servers which in this case we we don't
want to use them so this will be almost
like a test run for when we deploy this
for real on our main domain it'll be
slightly different when we do it for the
you know the root domain but only only
very very slightly just let's see
just to catch everyone up we see we're
pretty much in terms of design this site
is pretty much done there's a few like
little tweaks here and there that I'd
like to get to but the big thing that
we've been working on and that I've been
working on when I'm not streaming is
just getting data moved over from our
old server to our new server from an old
database to a new database and then
making sure that that data is able to
get into react properly and that the
URLs match up with what the old site has
so that's I don't I feel like I'm
knowing the same thing every day with
this site but I mean there's just a lot
there's a lot of data to handle so you
know that's how it is
so not really fun to do all that but but
necessary so I really do want to get
this test site up on what you ought to
be able to have a URL you can go to at
any time to check it out and I want you
know other users here to be able to
check it out and start pointing out to
me things that aren't working because
we're at almost exactly a month until
the launch date so I definitely want to
give as much time as possible for for
testing not just for me to test but for
other people to test all right okay we
should I need a few more viewers so I
guess we'll start up I do want to
mention though next week next Tuesday I
will be at the Google i/o extension
conference for Pittsburgh so Google the
Google i/o conference is going to go on
next week their main conference at their
headquarters but then all over I believe
it's all over the world they're gonna
have these extension conferences so
especially in places that have a Google
office so Pittsburgh has a branch of
Google there and I'll be there but the
reason I want to bring it up is
we're number one to say I definitely
won't be streaming that day but also if
anybody plans on going if you're in the
Pittsburgh area let me know it'd be
awesome to meet up if you want when when
we're at the conference and I'll try to
I'm not going to try to do a YouTube
livestream from there I don't think I
don't think there'll be an opportunity
for that but I may do something on
Instagram just some updates and things
so if you have Instagram and you don't
follow me you'll find me on Instagram I
think if you go to my youtube channel I
have Instagram link from there so if
you're interested in that sort of thing
you know
find me on there and I'll try to put
some updates in and then of course I'll
tell you all about it the next day when
I when I do have a chance to stream
let's see since we're talking about
conferences I'll also be at the
revolution conf in Virginia Beach that's
on in a couple weeks or something so
anybody in in Virginia or that general
area if you're if you're gonna be in the
conference awesome if you're not going
to be the conference but you're in that
area and like to meet up let me know
and I'll be speaking at the Pittsburgh
tech fest in June as well so anyway just
thought I'd like to let you all know
it'd be really cool I'd hate to be
somewhere where maybe where you all are
and then miss an opportunity to to meet
up or something so all right enough of
me talking we do have a question nikki
says is the material design version to
getting unveiled at Google i/o or is
that just a rumor I I don't know I'm a
been seeing headlines about this
material design version too but I don't
know for sure I would imagine if they're
gonna unveil it IO is probably the place
to do it that would be really cool so
I'm definitely interested in that
obviously since I used material design
for most of my projects okay so let's
start out let me share my screen so and
then we're gonna start out with the
domain name so let me I'm gonna do all
my login stuff on my other screen and
then move it over just so that I don't
accidentally give away any important
information and especially I believe we
have this domain hosted with GoDaddy and
I have quite a few GoDaddy account save
tiers I don't want to give away like all
seven of my GoDaddy usernames on the
screen at once they're not all my
accounts with their accounts I have
access to for clients and various
accounts at the University okay let me
see the University of several accounts
and I can't ever remember which one has
this this domain name so I may get the
wrong one first I think
all right I got the right one all right
so I'm gonna move this over there we go
let me move this over now I'm gonna do a
little explanation as well because I'm
just not sure how familiar you all are
with handling domain names DNS records
and things like that it's not something
you want to mess around with really
unless you know what you're doing so if
you're using a domain this is not really
linked up to anything then you know feel
free to mess around as much as you want
but if you're doing this for a client or
for a live website you want to be very
very careful because you can mess things
up especially I mean not only with I
mean really with any of the types of
Records you can mess it up but
especially with MX records you can mess
up somebody's entire email system which
I've actually done before for a client
years ago so it all got sorted out and
you know but there were a few days there
where emails weren't working so from
experience I will tell you it's
definitely a good idea to double-check
you know what you're doing you wanna you
know screenshot everything beforehand
because if for some reason you lose all
these IP addresses and would have to try
to remember them and look them up to go
back and it would take you much much
longer to get these back where they're
supposed to be so depending on where you
host where you manage your domain from
this panel is going to look different so
the admin panels are are very different
just depending on where you're at in
terms of the style the design but what
they should have is an area where it
lists your types of Records right now
these are all a records here you have a
name your value and then
you know some seconds here the usually
pretty standard I see is like 600
seconds
these correspond with subdomains right
so right now we have quite a few
subdomains here and the subdomains are
pointed to an IP address right so for
instance if you were to start up a
digitalocean droplet it has an IP
address right if you wanted that droplet
if you wanted your subdomain to go to
that droplet you would just take that IP
address and you'd put it in here as an a
record so if we want to begin dot
Franciscan University to go to our
droplet let's we just pop the IP address
in right there right and now sometimes
there's a delay it just it depends and
I'm hoping that there's not too much
delay when we do this otherwise we may
not be able to see the result for a
while but I wanted to do it with you
instead of doing it beforehand so
hopefully it will all work out and I
just remembered that I did not start my
timer here's the timer all right let me
start that up that way after after 25
minutes is over might take a break I'm
answer some questions there in the live
chat so first thing we need to do is
figure out what we want our our
subdomain to be for this so normally
like test or dev is a reasonable one if
this is going to be a test site so let's
see if we have that already okay we do
have test and we have test one
let's check page two
and page three just to be sure okay so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna make a
domain name called dev so it'll or a
subdomain called dev so the URL will be
dev dot Franciscan University so that I
mean that's a reasonable domain name I
think our sub domain so what we're gonna
do is select in this case a cname record
and we're gonna say dev points - and
this is where we need to get a value
from now so let's go to the now
documentation site now there we go and
once I get to the right page I'll paste
the link in the chat I see there's a lot
of activity in the chat just hey
everyone I'll definitely check out the
chat here in a few minutes so we're
gonna go to our documentation and assign
a domain name and let me make this much
bigger so you can see and I'm gonna copy
this and they said if anybody uses
Spotify the throwbackthursday playlist
is from the year 2000 which I was in
high school in the year 2000 set my
maybe middle school so maybe around
eighth grade or my freshman year
somewhere like that so if anybody shares
similar nostalgia for the year 2000
check out the throwback Thursday
playlist on Spotify okay so the links
paste it now in the chat if it doesn't
work when you click it please try to
copy and paste it and into your browser
directly and then that should work so
we're gonna try to do it with a cname
right so these other options you're
welcome to you
those and they may be better for your
use case but for our use case here
really our only option is to use the the
cname so we need to point it to alias
dot site Co and I believe it's alias I
just yeah yeah not I think about I did
this with another site recently and this
might be outdated we'll see if it is
outdated then maybe we'll submit a pull
request to update this but we'll find
out in a minute
so we we do need terminal window open so
let's see where this is all right I'm
gonna move this over so it's on the same
screen with us here and let me just get
a fresh a new tab there we go we'll just
start with a fresh one here and oops I
forgot to put it in I'm skipping a step
there we go we need to put that in here
alias site Co and we'll drop this down
to 600 right we want this to go as
quickly as possible all right so now we
have our cname record and so the
subdomain dev should go here so if if
you want your particular subdomain to
point to a URL use a cname if you want
it to point to an IP address use an a
record okay so that's kind of just a
really basic difference between the two
so let's let's see and I believe we'll
find out really quickly whether or not
that
was the the way to go I let's see you
know and I think we already have this
yeah let's go ahead and just do it over
here since this is already where we want
it to be now let's let's make sure we're
ready so we'll do a get pool I just did
one but I want I could do it on on the
stream so you'll always want to begin
work with a get pool because you may
have pushed something to github and you
didn't remember or somebody else that's
working on the same project may have so
you definitely want to make sure you
have the latest stuff so we do happen to
have the latest stuff and now I want to
let's just do a yarn so I know that I
didn't have any new packages but that's
another step that you always want to
take to make sure that you have the
latest packages if you're not using yarn
you can use NPM install I believe just
typing NPM works now as well now the
next thing we want to do is use our
commands from our documentation here so
what we're gonna do is type now alias
and we're going books option no we
actually need to type we need this first
so let's run now there may be a way to
combine some of these steps but since
we're going through it the first time I
think it'd be better to do it separately
anyway so what this is doing now that
we've typed in so I have installed now
on my machine so that's another step you
will have to take it's just to install
it if you go into the documentation for
now then you can figure there's there's
several ways that you can download it on
your machine so you can pick whichever
way works best for you
so we've been given this URL here so
base
default now URL is going to be the name
of your project plus kind of a random
string and then dot now dot Sh it's it's
nice but it's not really easy for a
tester or user to type in right we
wouldn't want that to be our our actual
URL for our website so we'll let that go
I mean it's this is taking all of our
files and running them on a server so if
I don't know how many of you were with
me whenever we've setup digitalocean
servers but compare that process which
if you're lucky and you do everything
right you can set up a server to run
reacts you know with SSL and everything
maybe in an hour right but this isn't a
matter of minutes and there's no
maintenance so while that's happening
I'm gonna check the the chat let's check
the time - all right sixteen sixteen
minutes
let's see David said ass is this like
Heroku I sort of yeah it's it's a way to
deploy okay so we are successful so what
it did which is kind of nice
is it automatically save this URL to the
clipboard which is cool we don't we
don't have to copy it so let's go over
here and just visit it to verify that it
is working and I'm gonna click around a
bit
wonderful
and see under graduates great back to
the homepage and let's make sure this is
working
wonderful looks like everything's
working great so that was that was
really fast right like this is our site
running in a production environment it's
fast it has an SSL I mean that's that's
amazing I mean I don't if you've never
gone through the process of setting up a
server yourself in the SSO and
everything like it may not seem like a
lot but it's really really amazing
I did see Nicki had a question about
this now also support separate
deployments per branch
I have deployed things different
branches before as well so I have a
deployment right now of the catechetical
Institute website that's just the
upgrade branch so that's that's
definitely a possibility you have a
branch that your latest stuff you want
to let your client see it before it goes
live let's say on the main URL you can
make a test subdomain and just push that
branch so all you would do is go into
you know you do a git checkout on that
branch and then once you're on that
branch you run now from that branch so
great great question and it's definitely
possible so now that we have this let's
type in now alias we're gonna paste this
in so we want this URL to go to dev dot
Franciscan University now it's not gonna
work this time
but that's to be expected but we need to
get some some info here because we're
going to need to set up a text record as
well to make this work and we're going
to get that record once this does its
thing
all right cool so we have this now and
you can see we have a few pieces of
information so first it says you could
set your name servers to this which
we're not going to do we're using the
alternative way and that's we've we've
already set our C name to use aliases ID
CO and now we need to make a txt record
that has this value so I'm definitely
gonna copy that value we're gonna copy
that and now let's make this record so
we're to go back to our domain I'm gonna
add a txt record and the host is going
to be underscore now and then there's
the value and we'll set this custom as
well and let's save and we'll see we now
have this txt record and let's compare
I have sex mission above the air message
okay I remember now this I remember
which part of this I had thought about
creating a pull request for so this
screenshot is from an older version of
of now so that's why it looks
differently so I had thought of
potentially replacing that it was yeah
so we're not gonna do that now cuz it's
it's not really a big deal because the
newer version explaining explains it
better when you're running the command
so now that we have that Tex record
again we're going to run this command
over again so where's that same command
and when we run it this time it should
work alright good so we have our success
message here so now it's going to
generate an SSL certificate and it's
going to set that up so this may take a
minute or so but once it's done we
should be able to go to Deb Deb
Franciscan University and see our site
oh wow that was really fast awesome so
let's go over here and we'll go to dev
whoops dev at University and you all can
try this out as well Deb Franciscan
whoops if I could spell it right let's
try that again
there we go yeah it works so I'm gonna
paste this into the chat and that way
you all can can check it out you can see
this definitely works we can click
around to wherever we want and it runs
and it's fast it's so fast this is why I
I don't know you know the details of how
things deployed on now end up being so
fast I'm sure there's more details on
the website
I remember reading something before when
it first came out but I'm not even gonna
try to explain it it is just fast so I
do want to I want to go over how you
would keep this up right so this is
great but what happens when you want to
update it so obviously like your site's
gonna change over time this sites gonna
change
it'll probably change you know today so
how do we keep things up to date easily
so there is a way to make this whole
process a bit easier in terms of
updating and let's see where it's at I
want to show you how to do this
I may not be able to find it in the
documentation you may just have to have
to just do it
alright I'll just do it I'm sure it's in
the documentation somewhere but it's I
still remember how to do this so here's
what we're going to do we're going to
add in a basically a new section into
our package.json that is going to have
configuration for now now there's a lot
of other options actually not let me
find this in the in here because there
we go okay here we are so we can put in
this Now option and we can put in an
alias we can add in it should have yeah
here we are
so we have all these other these options
of to configure now right there so named
alias we have like environment variables
which is very useful scale which we're
not going to worry about scaling now but
whenever we actually launch them the
site the the live version of the site
we're going to do some stuff with scale
so we'll explain it more then this is
like well still scale sub I that's oh
wait so there's a lot of different
things you can see I'm still scrolling
you know still with this configuration
but for now what we really need is is
the alias so that's what we're gonna
check out actually let me make sure I
have time to do this before my time
around oh five minutes yeah we're good
okay so what we want to do then is
where am I gonna put this all right I'm
just gonna put it here so we're gonna
make this now and so this is right our
package.json it's just a JSON file so
same format as normal we're gonna write
we're gonna have an alias and
and then for our alias we're going to
put in our URL so we're gonna go dev dot
the Franciscan University let me double
check that I spelled it right this time
there we go
all right so that is spelled correctly
all right awesome
and that's all we're gonna do right now
to set this up so I guess we could just
let's let's just test this out so I'm
gonna make an update now the updates
really not gonna do anything that a user
can see on the site but let's go let's
do get status we see we've updated that
let's do get ad and then we'll do a yarn
see em so this is how we've set up our
custom way to set up to make pull
requests though maybe
maybe we'll put under build I don't
let's do it
alias
okay so we'll let this run through roll
the test and then we will try this out
let's see
Oh
I'm not running the server that's why
let's do yarn dev oh oh it looks like
alright so I already have a server
running here so let's stop this
here we go we're gonna stop that one so
we can start this one up sorry about
that
you are deaf and it looks like we have
it came up with a message saying that
there's a new version of next so suppose
we're gonna be doing it up update to the
latest version of next sometime soon and
when this is done and now we'll try to
run this again 3d yarn cm but we're
gonna go with retry is that what it is I
think that's the command everyone nope
two of them there we go that's it so we
don't have to type in our commit message
and everything again when we use retry
with the double hyphens
so now it should work if you happen to
be working on this project and you run a
new similar issue just make sure that
you're running the server before you try
to commit because the test will try to
run but they can't without the server so
that did work so now we're gonna do now
right so you know what can we just run
now alias we may be able to run now
alias I I can't remember exactly
see we I don't think we have a search
I wonder if it says it down here
hmm I remember exactly where it is so
let's let's run now
so now we're gonna have another uro a
different one from the one we had before
it so there'll be another instance the
cooling about now is like like right now
I'm not on a paid plan I have a free
plan I can start these instances up and
it's it's entirely free we're eventually
going to move on to a paid plan which
will I might work on that today buying
things at a university usually involves
paperwork and going through stuff so I'm
gonna consult with my colleague about
what the best way that is to go about
paying for an account I think my timer
just ran out so I'm gonna scroll up and
start answering questions and then once
this is finished we'll run the next
command I should have changed something
so that we could see what was happening
in that website but it's too late now
this hurt
John Hanson says hey all summer like
today iced coffee time yeah the
weather's been really nice I mean I'm in
I'm near Pittsburgh and in the United
States and the weather is like 80
degrees super nice and I did get iced
coffee what day was a Tuesday Tuesday I
had dentist appointment and doctor's
appointment and so I stopped and got a
nice coffee between I just stopped in to
Dunkin Donuts and I'm glad I did they
had Wi-Fi and then one of my clients
websites from a long time ago crashed
and so they emailed me or like hey and
the sites down and so I checked it out
and was managed I managed to get it back
up and running while during my stop at
Dunkin Donuts in between my appointments
so that worked out really well and I
happen to have my laptop with me which
is also very nice okay so now that we do
this let's type now now alias and I
believe yep there we go so here's here's
we've done if you can't see that I'm
gonna read through a little bit but this
is assigning alias deaf deaf Franciscan
University to the deployment Franciscan
University react and then m'kay JD
whatever and that's the one we just did
so it's not our old deployment that we
just made like a half hour ago or so
about then this is a new one so now what
we're able to do every time we want to
push our new updates to our test site we
just cite now followed by now alias you
probably could do now and now it's so
like something like this now so you
probably could do it like this if you
want to do it all in one command which
is would save time you could just do it
and leave assuming that you're confident
that
errors will happen but yeah so basically
now all you have to do is just this
command it will deploy your new changes
to a new instance and then switch it so
let me think about like the beauty of
this is like we're talking about no
downtime when we update it's amazing
like normally let's say we have a
droplet on digital ocean or server
somewhere and we only have one server
you go in you go to update what do you
need to do if you're using like get for
deployment you need to do a get pool you
need to build right and then you need to
start that server again so that means
there's going to be a period of downs
I'm depending on how long your build is
like how fast your servers there's gonna
be a little downtime it might not be
that much but you don't want to deal
with that what we've done here is we
have our instance right so it's like we
have a server that's running like
imagine under the ocean you were running
two servers right load-balanced so you
shut one down all the traffic goes to
the other and then you do your updates
and then you switch to the other one do
your updates right buttom but think
about all the work that goes into that
setting up two servers paying for two
service even if you go with five dollar
servers it's still ten dollars a month
to do the digitalocean load balancing
that's $20 a month for the load balancer
so now you're up to $30 a month in the
process to update still if you haven't
really automated anything it's still
logging into a server doing your get
pool doing a build starting to backup
logging into another server repeating
the same process right and that's only
with two if you have multiple servers
you could be even more involved where we
have an instance running and our domain
name is pointing to that instance we get
another instance up and running with all
our changes and then when that one's
ready we
simply point the domain to the new one
there's zero downtime right well we
don't have to worry about the Oh the old
one is gone in terms of it from the
users perspective I could still use that
old really long URL and get to it but
it's just gonna get shut down right it's
gets gonna go to sleep and it's not
going to be active anymore and now we
have a really fast way there's no
logging into servers it's all right
there for the command line type in now
and now alias and it's ready I mean it's
there's definitely advantages to this
way of deployment so okay I'm not
getting paid to promote this or anything
like that
I'm just very impressed by it so I'm
gonna get to the questions now in SSI
michael says hi hey how's it going
the vet says does data rendering always
happened through Ajax call and react
except for server-side rendering yeah I
mean you can use fetch instead of Ajax I
mean you're probably going to do fetch
but yeah I mean basically if you're
gonna do if you're gonna get data on the
fly client-side that's that's the way to
do it
Shaniqua says hello hey how's it going
thanks for watching Michael said I'm
already lost I didn't take long
sorry Christian says hi and how are you
today not not bad in also asks how my
day is going so yeah days not bad
what's up early with the baby and didn't
really get anything done even though I
was up early because I was trying to
keep her entertained in a room and quiet
so that she didn't wake up everyone else
in the house so didn't get a chance to
work out this morning definitely gonna
try to work out when I get home though
and so I I started I like I'm bringing
this up kiss you last time I day is so
apologies to those who just want to know
about the code but briefly to give you a
little update on my life so I you all
know that I you know battled depression
and exercise definitely helps me a lot
so I've been trying to exercise more and
I've also added to that I'm on a diet
now so I weighed myself on Saturday and
I weigh significantly more than I've
ever weighed before my life I weigh I
weigh 290 pounds two years ago I weighed
150 pounds so it's a definitely a huge
increase so I decided to go on a diet I
mean I don't I don't look like I'm
overweight but realistically 190 pounds
is probably you know too much for
someone who's 5 foot 10 so decided to go
on a diet really weird for me I've never
really been on a lose weight diet before
so I'm in the middle of that so my
eating habits are different I'm it's not
like a really complicated diet it's just
taken you know less calories then then I
burn more calories and I take in right
that's that's the plan but with that I'm
trying to make sure that I'm
some eyes the amount of protein I eat
and I'm trying to do do workouts so
cardio workouts weights things like that
as much as I can get in so that's where
I'm at so so far I've lost five pounds
since Saturday which i think is good I
haven't really said I read haven't
really dieted that much so but I'm
trying to feel it out so I think I'm
probably taking in too few calories
because my muscles aren't recovering as
fast as they normally do so I might have
to adjust it a bit but anyway so far I
actually feel I feel good my depression
is not bad at all so maybe maybe I'm
like accidentally stumbled on some other
helpful thing of you know kind of eating
healthier will also help my depression
which now that I say it it sounds like
hey why didn't I think of that before
but i realistically just never
correlated my diet with my depression so
anyway that's my mental health and
personal life story for today hey
christian says you're not using webpack
for this well I mean web packs involved
in some of the process in terms of like
the build right so when we use a next
web pack is like pre-configured so
there's a lot of web pack going on
behind the scenes but we don't directly
configure anything
John Hanson says they're talking about
URLs is there a way to write an anchor
tag URL href to search a string in the
visitor zone default search engine and a
new window hmm I've never tried that or
even thought about doing that before
yeah I'm not sure yeah I don't know
about the users default search engine
I mean potentially you could have you
could open a new window with a string
that would like automatically put in
whatever you want to search for like
into a search query if that's how that
search engine works
so then it would give you results what's
like you know you can search for
something on Google and then copy and
paste that URL and then somebody else
can see those results so I mean
essentially you just need to build that
URL like that so I mean it's but I don't
know how you would know what their
default search engine is I don't I don't
know of any any like browser API that
lets you know what their default search
engine is not to say it doesn't exist
I've just never heard of it
Rizwan says hello hey how's it going
thanks for watching Evo says hey hey
how's it going
Evo says quick question are using
typescript with react if so how do you
handle styling no I'm not using
typescript with with react so I haven't
really done that much with typescript
I'm not against I script I just just
haven't really used it Evo says just in
general how do you handle styling and
react without styled components I've
imported CSS files with classes into
components for that just feels dirty for
some reason yeah I mean there's a lot of
different ways to do styles in react so
as far as I know there's not one way
that's like this is the best way you
have to do it like this there's a lot of
different ways generally you know having
your CSS somewhere in the actual
component that seems to me to be the
best way to handle things because then
your components become you know very
modular and reusable so there a variety
of ways to accomplish that so whatever
way works best with you and what your
overall system I think is fine
phoenix is here phoenix says hello hey
how's it going since you started early
today I did I started a little early for
a time I was starting the streams at
like 11:00 a.m. Eastern Time which is
even earlier than I did today I just
kind of got off track with different
meetings and things going on
hey Frankie's here says hey sensei how's
it going
let's see Eric knows best says what do
you recommend to learn react
check out the react documentation the
latest version of free code camps are
the beta version has some react stuff in
it as well I personally haven't gone
through it yet so I don't I don't know
if that's enough to really learn it says
react code Academy has react course yeah
that's where I would go to do to do
react and then of course there's there
are plenty of YouTube tutorials we have
someone on the free code camp channel so
I mean that pretty much as you covered
you know between video texts if you're
going to do the react documentation or
like guided learning in terms of the
code Academy course between those that
should give you a really good
introduction you know no matter what
your learning style is
all right Nikki says it's immutable yeah
a new URL SRI's deploy and all I were
writing was already there that's awesome
yeah for sure
super super us Frankie says are you
fasting Eric's is intermittent fast
intermittent fasting is the best yes so
I I'm not purposely doing intermittent
fasting I in like practice though I have
been holding off on eating till later in
the day that's just kind of been like
I've been waking up later than normal
and they haven't had time to eat so I'm
just like okay well I'll just wait so
I'm not purposely doing it I need to
learn more about intermittent fasting
because if I'm gonna do it I want to do
it the right way I don't want to like
mess up mess myself up so I'm not I'm
not actually doing it I'm I said I'm
just tracking all my calories I'm
tracking my protein and you know I'm
just making sure that I burn more
calories than I take in at this point
Frankie says thanks for sharing your
story with us oh yeah no no problem I
just I always get nervous when I share
because I wonder how many people
actually care about that kind of stuff
and if you'd rather just do more coding
so yeah but I don't I don't mind sharing
as long as you are somewhat interested I
guess John says five pounds is often
just water weight especially when eating
more protein long term of comparison
weights will tell more ok cool that that
actually explains it more because I kind
of thought like five pounds seems like a
lot of weight right like how do I lose 5
pounds and what's five days and it's so
that that makes more sense
Christian says thank thank you for
sharing man would you do on this channel
it's awesome and it really helps me to
learn react faster I'm new to react No
yes and all that oh you're welcome I'm
really glad that this is as helpful to
you
michael says when the browser send them
to default search page so this goes back
to the question about the search well I
don't I don't know because if you're
gonna put that search string in it's
it's going to be a URL to a particular
search engine so you would there'd have
to be some way to find out what the
default search page is so you can
construct the proper URL at least that's
that's what I'm thinkin maybe there's
some other way that I'm missing our
should see hey I should so I was unable
to make it some work came up oh yeah no
problem are I Frankie says we care
thanks I appreciate that John says
homeostasis is that endorphin high while
your body readjusts enjoy it wow it
laughs okay
so cool so John John knows what's going
on then so evidently I'm gonna have this
this endorphin high while I'm switching
into my diet mode so it's actually good
to know that it won't last so now I
won't think something's wrong whenever I
lose that feeling OSHA says title on
homepage says my page still in dev face
does it still say my page oh yeah it
does I make sure I change that good good
eye on there are so there's a change
yeah it never changes all right
definitely got to make sure that changes
all right um well I've gotten to the end
of all the questions on the chat we only
did one Pomodoro session of coding
because I mean we got everything done
and once we didn't really need it still
ended up getting an hour-long stream in
so if there are any more questions and
you get them in here within the next
minute or so I can get to him otherwise
I think I'm gonna you know finish up the
stream now Phoenix says I've started 30
days 30 sites I now know I need to pick
up my pace of development yeah Wow so
you're gonna build 30 websites in 30
days that's crazy
that's really crazy let me know how that
goes Phoenix that's that's interesting
all right so
Christian s is the whole page in
JavaScript react and nodejs
yeah yeah I mean that's pretty much what
we're using in terms of on I mean we got
we got some other stuff going on on
different servers in terms of content
management database but on the react
server I mean that's that's what it is
react with next J s we have Apollo for
graph QL and then we have node I mean
we're running Express with node but I
mean basically yes it's all it's all
JavaScript on those react servers all
right well I think that's it for this
stream thank you so much for watching
this is one of the rare times when
everything went right we didn't have any
problems I'm happy about that see it was
smart Friday I'm gonna try to stream
tomorrow I will be at home tomorrow so
hopefully I get a stream in still
working on that stream quality so I
can't guarantee anything but I'll try my
best to stream and to give a good
quality stream so hopefully I'll see you
all tomorrow if not next week on Monday
and and so then have a great day
maybe a great weekend I'll see it